ja ich hätte einfach nicht kommen sollen
sie hat ihr bactalent verloren
hat sie doch
[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen in Sallys Welt
heute habe ich Lust auf eine etwas
leichtere Torte ich möchte eine Torte
machen die an einem Gin Tonic erinnert
es gibt ja auch Gin Tonic alkoholfrei
also Gin alkoholfrei könnt ihr gerne mal
probieren und zwar habe ich mir jetzt
gedacht machen wir was mit Blaubeeren
und Limette und dafür habe ich mir jetzt
den Teig überlegt eigentlich wollte ich
den komplett laktosefrei machen da ich
jetzt Sonnenblumenöl verwende aber ich
nehme auch Schmand dazu ihr könnt aber
auch ganz gerne was laktosefrei ist
natürlich dazu nehmen oder statt Schmand
zum Beispiel
was können wir dann nehmen ihr könnt
auch Tonic Water nehmen oder ihr könnt
Buttermilch auch Laktose egal mach den
Teig einfach so wie ich also ich zeige
euch mal kurz die Zutaten dafür verwende
ich vier Eier 200g Zucker etwas Salz und
Vanilleextrakt 100 g Sonnenblumenöl 200
g Schmand eine Limette davon etwas Saft
und auch den Abrieb 200 g Mehl plus
Backpulver oder ihr nehmt mein backmehl
und 50 g gemahlene Mandeln ich nehme
jetzt die Eier Zucker Salz und Vanille
und schlagt die Zutaten etwa 5 Minuten
cremig den Ofen hat sich jetzt auch
schon vor und ich backe das Ganze gleich
in zwei Tortenringe mit 20 cm
Durchmesser ihr könnt aber auch eine
nehmen und das ganze hörbacken und dann
später durchschneiden
[Musik]
so sieht die Masse jetzt aus jetzt gebt
ihr die Flüssigkeiten dazu also Öl und
Schmand ich muss zugeben ihr könnt
Schmand nehmen ihr könnt Creme fraîche
nehmen ihr könnt Joghurt nehmen alles
was da ist und offen ist alles was
ebenso diese milchige Struktur hat und
schön weich da gucke ich auch oft
einfach was vielleicht aufgebraucht
werden muss Reste die noch verbraucht
werden müssen es könnte alles schön hier
mit rein backen dann die Limette davon
holst du dann hier davon den Abrieb und
da einfach drauf achten dass es Limetten
sind deren Abrieb man eben auch mit
verzehren kann
den Rest könnte immer ganz gut auch
abreiben wenn er nicht alles nimmt und
einfrieren in so einem kleinen Schälchen
ganz verschlossen und dann habt ihr
immer Limetten abgeschlagen
ich finde Limetten sind so die am besten
ist ein Wort Limetten sind die
Zitrusfrüchte für mich die am besten
duften
die sind so aromatisch
einfach
wow wir machen mal
statt
kurz einrühren bisschen Saft habe ich
dazu
und jetzt backmehl und Mandeln dazu und
nur ganz kurz einrühren
[Musik]
dann habe ich jetzt hier wie gesagt die
zwei Springformen 20 cm und weil es ein
sehr flüssiger Teig ist also das sieht
man auch immer ganz gut hier und der
eigentlich relativ gut auslaufen kann
nehme ich hier meine Springform bilden
da habe ich hier die Backfolie
dazwischen und einfach den Tortenring
wenn ihr das nicht habt dann könnt ihr
den Backring einfach auch mit Backpapier
einschlagen da gibt's auch schon ein
Video von mir wie ich zeige wie das
funktioniert und ich nehme jetzt einfach
zwei damit eben gleichmäßig backt und
eben der kürzere Backzeit hat nämlich 30
Minuten wenn ihr das ganze den ganzen
Tag in einer Form backt dann backt das
schon mindestens eine Stunde
[Musik]
der Kuchen ist gebacken und kühlt jetzt
gerade aus jetzt kann ich schon mal die
blaue Erfüllung machen dafür nehme ich
tiefgefrorene Blaubeeren das sind
nämlich die die auch im Inneren rot sind
200 Gramm davon landen jetzt hier in
meinem Topf dann 50 Gramm Zucker und den
Saft einer Limette dazu und das Ganze
schön einkochen
[Musik]
um nicht allzu lange warten zu müssen
bis das hier einkocht und eindeckt könnt
ihr auch gerne einen Esslöffel stärke
mit etwas Wasser anrühren hier dazu
geben und dann ist es wie so eine Art
Pudding und stickt eben auch schnell ein
oder ihr könnt auch als Bindemittel
etwas aka also pflanzliches Geliermittel
verwenden
dann fülle ich das ganze um und lass es
kurz abkühlen das hat jetzt immer so
eine richtig tief dunkle Farbe aber
sobald es dann zum Beispiel mit Sahne
oder mit hellen Cremes in Verbindung
kommt so richtig die pinke Farbe zum
Vorschein so wie im Topf
also habe ich jetzt hier folgende
Bestandteile die blaubeerfüllung dann
habe ich noch hier zwei Zutaten für die
Glasur nämlich Puderzucker und Zitronen
bzw Limettensaft habe ich eine Limette
und Blaubeeren für die Deko und die zwei
abgekühlten Tortenböden das kann ich
hier die Tortenböden erstmal rauslösen
am besten packt ihr die nach dem
Abkühlen noch mal in den Kühlschrank
den ersten packe ich jetzt schon mal
eine Tortenplatte ihr könnt ja auch
gerne wenn ihr sagt ihr mögt ihr dünnere
Böden auch gerne noch mal durchschneiden
und wenn man sie nicht durchschneidet
dann ist es so ein bisschen amerikanisch
weil in amerikanischen Rezepten oftmals
Tortenböden eher dick benutzt werden
die haben es halt nicht so mit der
Patisserie das ist schon so ein bisschen
grobes backen aber so französisches
backen und deutsches Backen das sind
immer schöne dünne Tortenböden das ist
schon feine weil sich da die Geschmäcker
besser verbinden
also habe ich mir meine Antwort schon
selbst gegeben
und wir schneiden die Tortenböden durch
nur bis dann optisch ja
schneiden wir durch
[Musik]
schöner und feiner aus ich berühre jetzt
hier allerdings noch den Saft den
Limettensaft mit Puderzucker wenn ihr
jetzt so richtig schön Tonic mäßig eine
Kuchen machen wollt dann könnt ihr hier
natürlich auch schön verwenden oder
Tonic Water geht natürlich auch es gibt
ja auch alkoholfreien Gin dann könnt ihr
auch gerne nehmen
und dann sollte ich hier ein schöner
dickflüssiger Guss entstehen
dann kommt jetzt etwas Marmelade
zwischen die Böden
wenn wer will kann natürlich auch noch
eine sahne Creme Quarkcreme oder
Mascarpone Creme dazu machen aber ich
finde es soll jetzt mal so ein Kuchen
sein der einfach ohne Sahne Quark
rauskommt richtig schöner fast schon
sommerlicher Kuchen
[Musik]
oh wer ist denn da ein Frederick
hier
hast du dich hier rein gebeamt willst du
gleich einen sommerlichen schönen
leckeren Gin tonic-kuchen ohne Gin
probiert gerne ja
falls ihr neue da draußen seid lasst
doch mal ein Abo da und like bei 20.000
likes machen Sally und ich ein
backformat einfach gelogen
der top-kommentar so heißt die
backsendung jetzt heißt es irgendwie so
Minecraft LP 9000 die Show oder so weil
die Leute irgendwas
ich habe
aufgepassting Management also ich habe
ein paar coole Ideen
zum Beispiel
[Musik]
ich habe mir Zett vergessen
tschüss mein Schatz komm gib mir noch
einen kussmäuschen
[Musik]
ist es noch
Ella ist es noch okay von Mama einen
Kuss zu kriegen
ja
darf ich dann noch mal eine Bitte
ja mann jetzt ist noch nicht so wie in
meiner Vorstellung ich musste noch mal
auseinanderbauen da muss noch doch noch
Creme dazwischen man muss doch die
Marmelade sehen
wie kriege ich denn jetzt wieder runter
natürlich kriege ich den runter
entschuldigung ich habe einen backkanal
haha
ich schlage jetzt einfach noch
Sahnesteif mit Sahnesteif mit seiner
Party
bei mir in der Küche ist mein Kopf
komplett ne lass mal Kopfhörer
hi solange die sahneschweißen schlagen
wird hier noch ein paar Ideen für
nächstes Jahr ihr könnt ja mal in den
Kommentaren Vorteilen Idee Nummer 1
die Lara und er macht wildetanz Videos
einmal die Woche Idee Nummer zwei
Murat fängt an mit tiktok und redet mal
lautstark über seine Meinung auf tiktok
und guckt wie lange es dauert bis der
Kanal gesperrt wird
die Idee Nummer drei ähm wir beide
machen zusammen eine Show in der ARD
Mediathek so wie äh diese dieses alte
Ehepaar und ziehen nur noch Rollkragen
und wir ersetzen die für eine Folge und
Kriegen dafür ganz viel Geld äh Ideen
Nummer vier
Weihnachtskarten ne ich habe gar nichts
vor Ostern geschenkt
ich muss meinen Kuchen retten oh mein
Gott
[Musik]
wow ich hätte einfach vorher mit denken
sollen sieht so aus wenn
Freddy manchmal wenn du meine Torten
nach machst sieht es dann auch so aus
dem Boden gekommen
ich hätte einen Keksteig gemacht
das wird schon okay Sahne und dann hier
rein und dann Schichten mit der
Marmelade ja und dann sieht so aus
da sind wir wieder drauf
und von Youtube kann man leben oder
es geht so also ich habe die Frage öfter
die wird mir tatsächlich öfter gestellt
und gerade
von dem Kochkollegen gefragt worden
und dann habe ich da losgeht es ist okay
viel besser geworden durch deine
Produkte shop.de
cool
kann man das Video einfach auf deinem
Kanal hochladen und meiner bleibt sauber
[Gelächter]
ich versuche jetzt noch zu retten was zu
retten ist aber aus meiner Torte die
eigentlich ohne Sahne sein sollte wurde
jetzt eine krasse Sahnetorte
ich wollte es unterdrücken aber es ging
nicht mehr oh Gott oh Gott oh Gott die
Torte ohne Sahne
Käse
mit rein
nachdem
geplant aber
ich finde den so ganz hübsch
ich überlege jetzt gerade ob ich jetzt
einfach in dem Stil weitermache
aufräumen
was sagst du
soll ich jetzt so in dem Stil
weitermachen oder einfach aufräumen
vorher
ja also normalerweise
[Musik]
hier und dann habe ich mir jetzt gedacht
wenn dann der Kuchen gefüllt ist mit
ohne Sahne
kommt die Glasur drauf
die wieder fest geworden ist
läuft bei mir heute
und dann kommt das hier so drauf
unterstützen oder so mental Schokolade
vielleicht mache ich einfach nur ein
bisschen was drauf
dann kommt das hier so drauf
wirklich keine Ahnung
was mache ich denn jetzt noch
die Torte die gerettet werden musste
können wir das das so nennen
ich glaube ich weiß wie das Video heißt
Freddy ich habe mein backtalent verloren
dafür bin ich ja da gar kein Problem ich
werde das wieder fein säuberlich
aufsammeln und dann geht's weiter ja
Bergkräuter
ich finde keine Tassen ich mache einfach
denn losgegangen
jetzt klatschen dann stimmt der Übergang
Freddie hat die Torte jetzt fertig
gebacken ich habe mir super viel Mühe
gegeben Deko ist meine Spezialität ja
ich muss kurz Weinen gehen
hat sie doch
nicht ganz so schlimm aus
alle Mitarbeiter
ich würde sagen wir machen jetzt
trotzdem mit professionelles
Fotoshooting meiner Torte und dann
probieren wir sie
[Musik]
ich weiß die Torte ist eigentlich viel
zu schade zum Anschneiden ja es sieht
schon wirklich
[Gelächter]
Zucker Samira kann schönere Torten das
gut backen schöner als das hier ja
ich finde du hast ein Top Job immer hier
siehst du die layers
[Musik]
ich habe sie auch aus dem Konzept
gebracht vertraut mir sie kann das
eigentlich wirklich gut
ich war so
ein Tag ich hatte heute eigentlich viel
Videos geplant
[Gelächter]
dann war ich abgelenkt dann habe ich AUA
dann habe ich einen Einkaufen noch was
sage ich dir immer macht das hier alles
zu hier kommt keiner rein und Fenster
ausbauen dafür Stahlbetonplatten
sowieso ein raketenbunker schaut gerne
nochmal die Haustür an die wir gemacht
haben die steht hier im Eingangsbereich
von der ganzen Bude da ist die Tür wenn
man klingelt das kann ich dann ernst
sein du machst das da hinten bitte ich
bin auch Empfangsdame
eigentlich musst du so noch mit der
obersten Schicht probieren also einmal
so ein riesenstück okay okay
sagt übrigens auch immer das Auge
gewöhnt sich ansässlicher
renoviert hat und aus Versehen die
falsche
silikonfugenfarbe gekauft hat
nämlich ein sehr komisches braun und im
Badezimmer sehr komisches Braun hat
immer gleich so eine
hat mir immer gleich so eine Assoziation
mit anderen braunen Dingen und da hat er
das verfugt dann habe ich der Papa ich
glaube das ist die falsche Farbe und das
sagt dann nein das trocknet dann ist
getrocknet und war immer noch braun und
dann hat er gesagt das Auge gewöhnt sich
anders hässliche richtig geil
ach quatsch ja aber ich muss sagen das
schmeckt richtig gut vielleicht bekommt
ihr den ja auch schöner hin wenn ihr
sagt Sally backt den Kuchen noch mal
schön dann backe ich den auch gerne noch
mal schön
bei 10.000 likes natürlich nur haha
ansonsten bleibt genauso wie es ist
kommt das so auf der Webseite ja auch
geil
die brauchen so eine unrealistische
Challenge sowas wie
40.000 likes oder so
backe ich die Torte neu oder wir machen
es mal umgekehrt das wird ein ganz viel
Auswirkungen
bei 40.000
[Gelächter]
okay
ich würde jetzt schon sagen ich mag sie
morgen neu damit schön ist aber wenn ihr
sagt mir lassen sie so oder lassen gut
aber auch nur wenn das auf der Webseite
kommt und mein Gesicht in so einem
kleinen Kreis unten drin ist damit die
Leute akzeptieren dass es so aussieht
es war nicht deine Schuld das war meine
Schuld ich war einfach heute nicht so
aber das okay ist okay ist auch nur
menschlich ja gell genau und man kann
immer noch Cake Pops draus machen
richtig okay also ab ins Frittieröl
keine Ahnung aber ich bin mir sicher man
frittiert und ihr könnt ja gerne
das wird unsere neue Idee wir machen mit
Freddy frittierte Cake Pops
[Musik]
oh mein Gott okay neue Video Idee also
ihr seht uns bald beim Cake Pops Formen
und Frittieren
aber wir nehmen keinen Plastikstab der
schön
also bis zum nächsten Mal und das Rezept
findet ihr mit wunderschönen
Rezeptbildern auf sallys-blog.de
tschüss
[Gelächter]
so magst du dieses Stück noch gönnen ja
ich kenne das ist weg dann muss es
keiner mehr angucken
was ich dir jetzt
ich lasse es so ja
ich lass es wirklich so ich packe die
nicht noch mal neu oder ja nein doch
nein
[Musik]